iv à restreindre un petit peu leur
contenu pour soir ici radio riposte la
radio des socialistes de paris 19h la
radio clandestine des socialistes de
paris commence son émission dans les
combles du 12 cité malesherbes l'un des
sièges du ps françois différence
explique que pendant une heure
l'émission rapporte m
lenny les traits du radio libre à partir
de sa fédération de paris les grands
scandales minutes plus tard radio
riposte est brouillée une première fois
20h l'émission est finie les premiers
policiers en civil écédente les élus
socialistes laurent fabius paul quilès
michel charzat et le sénateur parmentier
téléphone qui à l'assemblée qui au sénat
et même à l'elysée pendant ce temps des
renforts de police arrivent des
spécialistes comme un stade défoncé la
porte
laurent fabius 5 heures je suis
extrêmement choquée comme démocrate est
profondément attaché aux libertés c'est
la première fois dans l'histoire
à ma connaissance d'un gouvernement
donne l'ordre d'enfoncer les portes d'un
parti politique
21h30 la porte est tombée des gaz
lacrymogènes ont envahi le hall le
commissaire foucher tente une dernière
fois de convaincre les élus socialistes
de le laisser passer
situation elle est agréable avec une
façon de la dénouer ces deux parties
à 22h30 un par un les responsables du ps
sont évacués on l'a vu le niveau
précédant cet incident
les mineurs attention que vous faites
bien on ne vous fait pas vraiment ou non
doit aussi lancer des sandales et engagé
mais une bande de sales of fate le
caméraman poussé par un policier en
civil tombe dans l'escalier pierre-alain
je dois vous étiez en compagnie selon
sans succès pour trouver l'émetteur de
nouveaux incidents se produisent dehors
sur le trottoir de la cité malesherbes
où un cortège de manifestants et tarifs
vers 23 heures les policiers sont venus
viennent l jospin le numéro deux du ps
fait l'inventaire des dégâts et
s'explique
vous saviez pourtant que la diffusion de
cette émission était illégale écoutez
nous avons écouté au siège du parti
socialiste
une émission sur les libertés nous ne
pensions pas que cela fournirait un
prétexte de plus au pouvoir
pour les bafouilles saviez bien calculer
le risque eh bien écoutez nous verrons
si cela servira le pouvoir que dassier
j'ai un parti politique et nous verrons
comment réagira à partir de demain
l'opinion devant ces mesures